[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in peter king football
morning in america must read column for
any football fan and also contributor to
nbcsports.com
pete thanks for joining us how would you
best describe the atmosphere last night
uh
surprisingly
100 percent
loving
i thought the fans did a fabulous job in
you know i was down on the field dan it
it started raining very lightly at 7 29
in foxboro at 7 30 tom brady walked out
uh to a great great ovation
and you know i had been around new
england a couple of weeks ago and
there's some people in new england and i
think quite a few of them who aren't in
love with tom brady the way they used to
be
but
fans really showed him love and then i
thought it was great
the first time that the tampa bay
offensive unit came on the field
there were thunderous booze
in the stadium which is exactly how you
should treat a visiting team no matter
whether tom brady's the quarterback or
milt plum is so
i thought the scene was was really cool
last night the other thing dan that
crowd stood for three and a half hours
it was interesting to see
who was the big winner last night if i
said brady belichick mac jones
mac jones
i mean
dan uh
you know imagine what could he be
thinking about look his life changed
forever six months ago when he had
nothing to do with
that being other than the fact he was a
good quarterback
he didn't he didn't you know hold a gun
to anybody's head and say draft me bill
belichick drafted him
and he came into this maelstrom this
brady versus belichick maelstrom
and last night he handled the pressure
and and dan
he took
three or four
shots
last night
big big shots
and he just came back and he kept
dinking dunking all over the field 19
completions in a row obviously at one
point
uh
mack jones dan you know what happened
last night
both teams won that game
because the bucks survived a tough road
game
against a
you know a guy who's got the answers to
all of the tests in bill belichick the
bucks survived they have major injury
problems somehow they've got to limp
through these games and find ways to win
while some of these defensive players
get healthy
and they don't have to play richard
sherman every snap
and and so they've got to figure out a
way they did for one night so this you
know the bucks are three in one
and as brady told me before he got on
the bus to leave the stadium he goes
listen
that's all that matters now what matters
is me falling asleep on the plane so
that when i wake up in the morning we
can worry about trying to be four and
one next week
i was surprised at the fourth and three
call
me too for
if tom brady is your quarterback
bill belichick
is not going to settle for a 56-yard
field goal in that kind of weather right
but you know what was weird about it dan
is and and i i just kept thinking about
this all right
so i don't know what nick foles because
they hired all their injuries but word
was last night that nick foles plant leg
is not 100
it was raining hard at that point
and you're asking him to make a 56-yard
field goal i mean the guy almost did it
he stoinked it
and and and but but anyway i just
thought
to get i would much rather with a minute
to go in the game
i would much rather
have tried for the first down with mac
jones
and if you get the first down then
you're in very makable field goal
position
so i was surprised and i thought it was
the wrong call by that okay but also
factor this in let's say you make the
field goal
i've given brady
55 seconds
two timeouts didn't make sense at all
even if you make it
brady can still beat you why not go for
it on fourth and three
and mac jones had been pretty good he
had had 19 in a row had a couple
incompletions and then it had a
completion and i just thought it would
have been one of those moments in front
of brady not that belichick wants to do
this but you'd be saying to your team
and matt jones hey
i trust you go out there exactly
i don't think it's that big a deal for
mac jones
you know to have the coach say hey i
trust you he hasn't really earned it yet
you know honestly
so but you're right the bigger issue is
you're leaving brady what would have
been about 55 seconds
uh and two timeouts
to go what 35 yards to kick another you
know a twin winning field goal i don't
know i didn't like him yeah we're
talking to peter king his column
football morning in america is available
right now
what do the steelers do
i'll tell you dan i didn't see their
game yesterday
but
i i mean the pittsburgh steelers are in
trouble and
i think the main
trouble comes from the simple fact that
you know okay what did the pittsburgh
steelers do in this off-season
you know what they did in this
off-season was say
we are going to we understand we've got
an old quarterback and we understand we
don't have a mobile quarterback but i'll
tell you what we're going to do this
year
we are going to help ben roethlisberger
by giving him a running game and by you
know changing up the offensive line
well last year and i think i'm right and
say in this day and last year
they were horrible running the ball 3.6
3.7 a carry whatever
well what are they this year they draft
a running back number one overall naji
harris and as we look at the numbers
this morning
they are 3.3 yards a carry
this year they're running it worse
than they ran it last year so
that plus the fact hey dan
this team
for three consecutive weeks has not
broken 17 points
you know they've not scored over 17 so
you were asking admittedly what's a good
defense
you're asking a good defense
to basically play games in the teens all
year that is simply not sustainable
the niners
drafted trey lance i think in part
because jimmy garoppolo can't stay
healthy
and
now you have this scenario playing out
where he's not healthy now trey lance
comes in
um
how do you think this plays out this
year even though garoppolo has played
pretty well i think by all accounts
i mean dan
there's a reason why
jimmy garoppolo was heartbroken
when the 49ers called him
in march and basically said we're
probably going to take a quarterback
um
and he's heartbroken because this was
his team and he thought that
they could recreate 2019
in 2021
and play great again but
kyle shanahan and john lynch
jed york
they
basically without ever saying it
i don't even think they would say it to
many people off the record
but how can you trust a quarterback
who's been hurt as much as jimmy
garoppolo has
who's played 23 of the previous 48
regular season games
i i just there's no way they could trust
them and i understand jimmy garoppolo
once more is heartbroken after getting
hurt again but this is the reason
why they decided to draft a quarterback
third overall now that i'd say two
things about trey lance that interest me
right now number one
in his limited time playing both as a
runner and a thrower
um he has not turned the ball over yet
and he's played a little bit in every
one of the games so far
so that is encouraging and i think the
second thing is he's going to be able to
get get out on the edge and i'm not
saying he's going to play
lamar jackson or or uh
you know or or you know tyler murray
tyler murray football
but i am saying that i think he's going
to be able to make more plays with his
legs than garoppolo did and by the way
um i i forget who i listened to this
morning very early when i was coming
back to the hotel after the game last
night but they said okay now if you can
get something for garoppolo before the
trading deadline go ahead and do it and
i said no no no
you keep your depth at quarterback when
you think you're a contending team
and so
the the 49ers basically are going to try
to win with lance and hope that he can
prove over the next few weeks that he's
the quarterback of the future if not
shanahan will have no problem going back
to garoppolo well if garoppolo's heart
is broken that's just another injury for
him though
yeah he's on the injury report this week
with parentheses broken heart end of
parentheses uh the arizona cardinals go
into la and
they rough up the the rams and that
great defense uh is it time to climb on
the arizona bandwagon
yesterday really i think became
it became convincing that you have to
climb on their bandwagon the two things
about that game that i found so
interesting
uh number one for the third straight
week kyler murray who was supposed to be
a good thrower but not necessarily
a a pinpoint thrower
is now the first quarterback in the long
history of the cardinals franchise
chicago st louis arizona to have three
straight games of 75 completions
so that's one thing but i think the
other part of this is
when the arizona cardinals hired cliff
kingsbury
one of the things that they said is look
this is not a usual nfl offense but the
one thing that this offense will do
is this offensive run the ball
and so far this year look they've passed
it just great but they still run the
ball very very well dan they're running
it 31 times a game
uh and and that's a lot of runs in
today's football so if they're running
it 31 times a game and they have a
quarterback playing as well as kyler
murray and they're scoring in the 30s
every week it's going to be a tough team
to beat
is dallas a running team now
no
dallas is a
just like arizona dallas to me is a
versatile team
uh who can pull anything out of its
uh bag of tricks any week
and
you know the cowboys to me
this is the kind of team they always
wanted to be
that
in some week if they needed to throw it
45 times they could if they needed to
run it if they need to run it 40 times
they can do that too
um and i think it also helps especially
in a 17 game season to have a two-headed
rushing monster you know like ellie or
elliott and pollard give you yeah i
agree i mentioned this at the top of the
show i wonder if those questions to
brian flores in miami
start to heat up a little bit with
deshaun watson and and i know brian
flores is not going to answer it but
uh i don't know it just feels like
losing that game jacoby brissette
against a banged up colts team you're at
home you lose by double digits
do you think that uh
that trade talk starts to heat up at all
this week
i think it depends on how hot it gets
uh for flores and for chris greer
i think the miami dolphins at one in
three especially with a double-digit
loss to a winless team
at home
um
you know they can't no matter who plays
quarterback for him
they they're not playing well on offense
uh
dan i i think that
as much as you never want to make a
panic move
and i don't
i don't i don't suggest that they make
this panic move
i think stephen ross is going to start
to get very impatient very soon yeah i
agree
great stuff as always pete thank you
again for joining us and uh safe travels
thanks a lot dan you take care that's
peter king football morning in america
nbcsports.com and
sleep deprived i'm sure